Mit Ansage! Mit Ansage: Das wird der nächste Hype!
Glaubst du mir das?
(H: Nah..)
Heeey! Das wird - Das wird's!
(H: Na komm, ich glaub an die Kikimunity! Komm!)
Leute, wir machen heute eine Oreo Torte. Ich hab' das vor einer Woche ungefähr ausprobiert.
Und es war irgendwann nachts, ich hatte so Bock:
"Ganz ehrlich, ich hab Lust auf 'ne Oreo Torte! Total unkompliziert mit einer Milchcreme und so ein bisschen wie die aus dem Kühlregal."
Und entstanden ist einfach ein unfassbar leckeres - Hm?
(H: Riesen-Oreo!)
Ein Riesen-Oreo!
Sieht aus wie ein XXL-Oreo - schmeckt richtig lecker!
Also wirklich: diese Milchcreme ist nicht von dieser Welt!
Und ich fange jetzt direkt an, die ganz genauen Mengenangaben stehen wie immer unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Das Rezept ist Anfänger-geeignet, ihr braucht wenige Zutaten
und mit ganz, ganz vielen Tipps von mir werdet ihr das auch als Anfänger gut beherzigen.
Und, was sagt ihr zu meiner neuen Küche? Zur Rückwand?
(H: Ja da fehlen noch die Böden!)
Da fehlen genau noch die Einlegeböden. Was sagt ihr? Schreibt mir mal in die Kommentare, wie ihr's bis jetzt findet.
Ich denke mal in den nächsten Videos werden dann auch die Einlegeböden da sein.
Ich muss sagen ich fühle mich richtig wohl! Vorher die Küche fand ich auch schön,
das Grau hat aber in der Kamera so ein bisschen zu grau gewirkt und jetzt haben wir ein warmes Holz im Hintergrund.
So! Leute,ich fange jetzt direkt an.
Ich hab' hier schon Vorarbeit geleistet weil Hamza war grad noch bevor er Play gedrückt hat am Telefonieren
und ich hier am Auspacken und die Oreos am Trennen. Jetzt habe ich nur noch 2 ums euch zu zeigen.
Hier, wir nehmen uns jetzt Oreo Kekse. Ihr könnt auch die Dupes nehmen, das muss jetzt kein Original Oreo sein.
Das Weiße, das trennen wir einmal. Also diese Creme, diese Füllung, die kommt jetzt erstmal hier rein
und der Keks nochmal separat.
(H: Also du sagst jetzt gleich, dass das kein Kooperationsvideo ist?)
Nein, das ist keine Kooperation! Alles hier auf freiwilliger Basis.
(H: Ehrenbasis!)
Ehrenbasis, genau!
So, jetzt ist das gleichzeitig unser Boden und auch unser "Deckel" also nehmen wir uns davon ein bisschen was weg
von den geschredderten Oreo Keksen.
(H: *schmunzelt* Geschredderten!)
So 2 gute gehäufte Esslöffel würde ich jetzt mal sagen..oder lieber 3!
Macht euch übrigens keine Sorgen: Alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben - also wirklich auch wieviel Gramm das jetzt ist -
steht in der Infobox. Da kann euch gar nichts schief gehen!
Da gebe ich jetzt geschmolzene Butter mit zum Großteil unserer Kekse weil das ja unser Boden ist.
Obendrüber braucht ihr dann keine Butter mehr.
So, einfach Butter mit dazugeben, kurz verrühren und dann auch schon in die 20cm Springform geben
und schön feste andrücken.
Die Springform geben wir jetzt bis zur Weiterverarbeitung in den Kühlschrank,
dann kann der Boden auch nochmal schön fest werden bevor wir gleich die warme Milchcreme draufgeben.
So, folgendes machen wir jetzt Leute - also das habe ich mir jetzt wirklich spontan überlegt
und es ist ein bisschen tricky aber beachtet einfach nur ein paar Tipps von mir:
Ihr nehmt euch jetzt Milch und gebt die in euren Topf. Den Herd noch nicht einschalten!
Und jetzt müssen wir die Creme ja irgendwie fest bekommen. Das funktioniert bei Flüssigkeiten wie Milch natürlich nicht mehr mit Sahnefest.
Da könnt ihr entweder Gelatine nehmen oder Agartine, also Agar Agar.
Das ist pflanzliches Geliermittel und das funktioniert so: - steht auch auf der Packung -
2min lang in Flüssigkeit sprudelnd kochen lassen.
Bei Milch ist das aber schwierig weil Milch brennt sehr schnell an.
Also was machen wir? Wir geben Agar Agar rein, rühren das um
und dann lassen wir das 2min ganz leicht nur köcheln. Ich hab's ausprobiert, die Creme wird sehr schön fest.
Und ihr müsst ständig rühren. Ihr dürft niemals aufhören, zu rühren!
So, jetzt schalte ich den Herd ein.
Die 2min gelten erst ab dem Moment, wo's köchelt und da mache ich mir den Timer an.
So, jetzt sind die 2min um. Da habe ich den Topf vom Herd einmal weggenommen, also weggezogen.
Mehr Hitze braucht die Milch nämlich nicht. Und die Agartine ist dann auch wirklich
wenn's runter kühlt Richtung 30° C wird das auch richtig schön fest. Das seht ihr dann aber nach der Kühlzeit.
Und wenn ihr alles richtig gemacht habt, dann dürfte jetzt am Topfboden auch nichts anbrennen.
Hier kann man's ganz gut sehen, da ist nichts angepappt.
Vielleicht liegt's auch an meinem Topf, das ist nämlich unserer!
Daran haben wir wirklich seit Anfang des Jahres also wirklich seit 10 Monaten dran getüftelt
und die sind seit vorgestern endlich da!
Verlinke ich euch natürlich in die Infobox, checkt das mal ab wenn ihr möchtet.
Und auch natürlich alle anderen Dinge, die ich hier so benutze, sind alle unten verlinkt.
So, da gebe ich jetzt einmal diese weiße Creme von den Oreos mit dazu
und das darf dann auch ruhig in der Resthitze so ein bisschen schmelzen.
Dazu gebe ich dann auch schon Zucker. Und der nächste Punkt, der super wichtig ist: natürlich Vanilleextrakt!
Extrakt schmeckt immer so ein bisschen intensiver als Vanillezucker.
Vanillinzucker bin ich sogar so frei und erlaube euch das gar nicht zu benutzen weil das schmeckt nur künstlich.
Also das Beste, was ihr je machen könnt, ist wirklich das Vanilleextrakt.
So, einmal verrühren!
Und zum Schluss in die warme Milch noch Doppelrahmfrischkäse einrühren mit dem Schneebesen.
Und bitte auch nicht die fettreduzierte Variante nehmen sondern wirklich Doppelrahmfrischkäse!
So, jetzt geben wir die ganze Masse in unsere Springform, die hab' ich grad aus dem Kühlschrank genommen.
Und solange das Ganze noch warm ist die Oreo Kekse oben drüber verteilen,
dann bleiben die nämlich schön haften und wenn ihr das Ganze anschneidet, fällt euch auch nichts runter.
Und das war's schon!
Ey Leute, ich bin grad - also wie krass ist das bitte?
Hamza wie lange haben wir gebraucht? Sei ehrlich!
(H: Ich glaub so 20min?)
20min mit Drehen!
Und ihr zuhause seid dann noch schneller!
Und jetzt müsst ihr stark bleiben denn die Springform muss zurück in den Kühlschrank.
Jetzt muss das Ganze fest werden. Gebt dem Ganzen 8h. Also wirklich mindestens 6h,
noch besser 8. Alles innen drin - der Kern von dieser Milchfüllung muss richtig schön fest werden und das braucht einfach Zeit.
Daher macht das auch gerne schon am Vortag wenn ihr wisst am nächsten Tag steht was an oder ihr wollt es einfach am nächsten Tag genießen.
Am nächsten Tag nehmt ihr euch dann einfach meine Winkelpalette,
fahrt am Rand der Springform entlang, dann löst sich auch alles gut,
nehmt einmal den Rand ab und könnt die Torte servieren.
Ganz ehrlich: Ich bin richtig begeistert von diesem Rezept!
Gut, dass es mir nachts irgendwann mal eingefallen ist und ich das Ganze direkt ausprobiert habe!
Unbedingt nachmachen, mir euer Feedback hier unter dem Video lassen
und abonniert meinen Kanal! Hinterlasst einen Daumen nach oben, wenn ihr mehr solcher Rezepte sehen möchtet.
Gerne auch Vorschläge mit anderen Süßigkeiten in die Kommentare schreiben.
WIr sind ja offen für alles, das wisst ihr ja mittlerweile!
Und dann würde ich einfach mal sagen: Bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen, Tschüss!
(K: Geil, ne? Geil, ne? *lacht*)
(K: Lohnt sich immer wieder, hierher zu kommen!)
Hammer, ne? Jetzt sein wir mal ehrlich: Das gibt's nur hier bei deiner Lieblingsschwägerin!
Ja, bin ich deine Lieblingsschwägerin? Sag's mal bitte!
Kamera weg!
Nein, Spaß.
(K: Ja, ne?)
Ey, wallah das ist cringe grad!
(H: *lacht*)
(H: Der checkt gar nichts mehr!)
Möchtest du - soll ich dir Nudeln machen oder möchtest du dich lieber mit deinem Stück Kuchen sättigen?
Nudeln würden 15min dauern!
Ähmm...
Also was cool wäre..
wenn ich jetzt sofort nach hause gehen könnte! Nein Spaß!